we're on season seven now of our new
show season seven of the new show yeah
Jersey Shore family vacation we just
started filming
um and and
uh and Angelina's in the mix yeah
and and everybody gets along with her
now
I mean she's drama I can tell you that
but I like I don't want problems with
her and I think she's fine like when we
party we drink she's fun she's a good
time but um you know she's she's the
drama of the show and she knows it do
the producers encourage the drama
back then they they definitely tried to
manipulate which we didn't realize yet
because you know like we're all riled up
so they get us more riled up and then
just goes crazy but now I'm just like go
away like I know how I know what to do
like don't yeah so it's just like we're
veterans at this point like you can't no
we're not scripted is what you're asking
yeah I mean well I think there's like
strings told behind the scenes like yeah
she said about you yeah I could see
other people being swayed like that
me I don't like the drama if I'm
involved in it whatever but like my my
thing was always to like go out have a
good time like I want to drink enjoy
myself like it's all about having a good
time on vacation so when I'm fighting
with my roommates or there's like [__]
going down it just I don't like it I
don't like drama I know you said that
it's not scripted was it but is it like
uh produced in a way where they're like
okay today you're gonna go to this
certain bar after you get out of work
and you guys are gonna do this and then
tomorrow you're gonna go to this certain
store oh yeah and back then it wasn't
like that because it was like legit 24
7. we were on camera for two months
straight like going to bed waking up
cameras in your face now it's more
different because we have kids so I
don't like that like I can't be away
from my kids for more than three days
um so it's kind of more choppy in a way
to like all right today we're gonna wake
up you know we're gonna go downstairs do
breakfast
um and then we're gonna go to dinner and
then you have this so they're telling us
things that we're gonna do but they
don't tell us what to do in scene we
just yeah do whatever yeah that's not
scripted but structure structure yeah
there you go yeah do you like shopping
on Amazon I do and good news is Stevo's
butt wipes for your butt hole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole plus
Stephen's butthole destroyer and Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right now
yeah dude